salut à tous et si on vous parlait d'un
joueur aérien un joueur classé tout
simplement numéro 6 pour la draft nba
2022 sur notre dernier big board il
s'appelle khandar brun en il joue à
baylor on va faire son portrait en 30
minutes chrono le profil de kendall
brown il est déjà sur notre site
envergure point c'est au vous pouvez
aller voir nos émissions sur youtube sur
twitch comme dan brown portrait de draft
et let's go c'est parti
pour brosser le portrait de kendall bras
trois fines lames dans cette émission
athos porthos aramis en quelque sorte
manu hugues alan salut messieurs
da luz pour commencer on va juste
préciser les les billets qui va y avoir
lors de la discussion qui vont présider
bernard et hughes a classé brandt
cinquième de son dernier big board alan
13e
manu tu n'as pas encore révélé ton
classement me sens utile mais ça ne
devrait pas tarder je viens de changer
en plus advient la changer battus nous
tu nous donnes tu nous donnera en
exclusivité
le changement de taux effectuées manu
donc t'as pas encore de big board sur le
site peut-être que tu en as non-officiel
en tout cas c'est toi qui vas commencé à
esquisser les contours de kendall brand
puisque c'est la première partie
maintenant vous connaissez le principe
première partie on vous donne une sorte
de fiche d'identité du joueur et en
deuxième partie on débat plutôt de sa
projection nba donc fiche d'identité on
commence par eux qui est il patrick
baldwin junior sa vie sa famille son
parcours hors canal bornes c'est le
l'élite freshman de belles or
né le 11 mai 2004 cottage bois ouvrent
dans le minnesota
donc il a des gènes à ces sportifs son
père a joué à sa hausse est sa source
missouri state et il est joué pro en
europe et en amérique du sud il a
également fait partie d allen globe
trotters
cas c'est assez marrant il en franges un
courtney band junior qui joue lui aussi
à en c est donc tout à fait deux ans a
mis l'audi la même université que
patrick baldwin actuellement et là il a
transféré à l'intersaison il joue
maintenant à saint-thomas ce minnesota
donc candle brand c'est un prospect 5
étoiles unanime à la sortie du du lycée
ou lite est avec kennedy chandler à
sannois christiane
mais il ajoute qu'un bon là-bas
autrement il a fait eastwood ch pendant
quelques sur ces deux premières années
on peut voir la sortie de ces deux ans
il est au lam et we can il a participé à
la partie il était sélectionné en équipe
suit également 2021 deux événements ont
pas pu se faire à cause de la situation
actuelle du coc vide il est il a été
suivi par tout les toutes les grosses
fac du pays arizona arkansas et les
nouilles kansas market etc donc il
choisit b lors
il a également fait plusieurs
tournois fin plusieurs mini camp de avec
team usa pour les pois les équipes mais
il n'a jamais été sélectionné il a fait
les mini-camps u16 et u17 900 jamais
faire partie des équipes finale voilà
très bien donc c'est un joueur qu'on
connaît déjà conquis et déjà référencés
et du coup il arrivait dans cette équipe
de baylor championne en titre donc nc où
ils se trouvent d'autres prospère on en
parlera plus tard
maintenant on continue sur kendall brown
et
j'aimerais que hugues nous parle de son
de son physique que à quoi
ressemble-t-il kendall brown et ben
écoute c'est un beau bestiaux c'est une
belle afro avec un joli bond au sein mec
qui est réfléchi sur le terrain vous
pouvez pas la rater il fait 2 m euros
pour 90 kg d'eau qui joue du côté de
belles heures en tant que ailier ailier
fort voire petit pivotant d'antan quand
il ya des problèmes de fautes
en termes d'envergure onex ge wind
d'envergure mesures et à 210 cm il
faudra voir les chiffres actualisés au
combat lorsqu'il ira à la draft parce
qu'il va y aller
c'est un prospect comme on l'a dit très
très athlétique ils montent très haut il
y reste particulièrement dans skins de
ses spécificités physiques et le club
allemand quand les défenses en train de
redescendre il est encore en train de
monter très agile notamment dans les
airs capable de changer de direction
d'adapter donc son geste et ses
premiers pas plutôt rapide même si ça
reste pas au niveau des élites et
n'diaye même pour les ailiers
latéralement il ya plus un défaut sur la
vitesse de pieds c'est pas vraiment
rentes de rotation des hanches et plus
la vitesse de pieds ou lorsqu'il va être
on ne va pas aller plus tard en défense
sur les extérieurs ça va être trop
compliqué pour lui et enfin pour
terminer je la côté puissance physique
c'est un joueur qui met de l'impact qui
met du contact et qui au niveau initié
prowl dessus physiquement sur ses
défenseurs direct que ce soit des
ailiers ou à l'intérieur
très bien très très complet kendall
brown s keita il apparut ida était
apparu qui s'est épaissie depuis le
début de l'année où il est plutôt stable
en terme de gabarit non j'ai pas vu une
grosse évolution je regardais les pois
plusieurs fois et j'ai pas trop
d'actualisation de là dessus donc pour
moi ça c'est assez stable
très bien pour terminer la carte
d'identité de kendall branle il nous
faut dire pourquoi pourquoi on parle de
lui comme d'un prospect billets qu'est
ce qu'il a à nous vendre et ça c'est
alan qui va en parler
si tu achètes
tu achètes un procès qui peut jouer je
propose 3 4 une bille est un joueur qui
peut défendre sur ses positions là une
menace de loeb aussi sur potentiellement
du deuxième rideau un joueur qu'on voit
peu cette année malheureusement ab l'or
en tant que poseurs d'écran plancher de
prendre une décision sur chartres hole
ville est souvent cantonné un corner je
pense qu'il ya une mauvaise utilisation
un peu de créativité cette année pour
son rôle à lui je pense quand même bien
il pourrait faire des choses en tant que
poseurs d'écran donc c'est un assez bon
passeur c1 jean qui sait prendre des
décisions un bon finisseur proche du
panier donc on achète un joueur qui pour
l'instant est serait le seul nom shooter
de ton sur sur le terrain c'est à dire
qu'il faudrait 4 shooteur à côté parce
que sinon l'espèce il serait un petit
peu problématique mais on achète un
genre qu'il ya potentiellement ce
potentiel de tir un joueur qui s'est
passé un joueur qui est à une très bonne
mentalité un joueur qui défend plusieurs
positions ça c'était pour la carte
d'identité messieurs maintenant on va on
va se charger de poser les questions qui
fâchent ou qui ne fâchent pas mais les
questions sa projection les bonnes
questions donc dans quel rôle est ce que
vous voyez
bringue dès l'année prochaine en nba
puisqu'on sait que la g-league est une
ligue de développement d'accor mais
c'est quand même mieux d'avoir du temps
de jeu en nba si on veut progresser donc
est ce qu'il aura du temps de jeu et si
oui qu'est ce qu'on va lui faire faire
moi je pense qu'il faudrait le
il faut pas le faire jouer comme on joue
cette année encore comme vous cette
année alors que le contenu dans un coin
donc je vais lui faire même s'il tire
pas vraiment non je crois que c'est 20 %
de ces tirs en tout qui sont prêts à
trois points comme il est cantonné dans
un coin on va soit il attaque un espèce
de faux clause out parce que les
défenseurs ne respecte pas trop son tir
soit il tire dans le corner moi je pense
qu'il faudrait en nba
l'utiliser un petit peu comme
comment memphis utilise brandon clark ou
comment par moments ayo astana qui
utilisent qui gagnent murray c'est à
dire poseurs d'écran sur pick'n roll
avec un gros un grand un côté qui peut
tirer lui donner un contre un dans la
pointure parce qu'il est plus athlétique
c'est un pathétique plus aérien il
pourrait terminer je pense qu'il faut le
faire il faut le rapprocher du cercle
dans la nba parce que là on je pense
qu'on on n'arrive pas à prendre toute la
mesure de ses qualités offensives à le
cantonner dans un coin gelé beaucoup vu
ces derniers matches j'ai l'impression
qu'il a une
petite évolution dans les systèmes qui
sont
dessinés pour lui par scott drew alors
il ya aussi eu des problèmes de
blessures à baylor donc il a eu un peu
plus la balle en main j'avais
l'impression de voir notamment face à
kansas lors du dernier match que j'ai vu
que tu m'arrête si je me trompe des
systèmes
quand on dira pas similaire mais quasi à
ceux qui étaient destinés à florida
state pour scotty barnes l'année
dernière c'est à dire qu'on va le faire
arriver
avec c'est lui qui va remonter le ballon
il va prendre de la vitesse
puisqu'il l'a pas un premier pas comme
tu l'as dit fou et on va lui poser un
écran et ensuite il va essayer de faire
faire le décalage est ce que toi c'est
ce rôle là dans lequel tu l'imaginent
vraiment dans le meilleur des mondes bah
c'est vrai que je rejoins avec alan fait
ce qu'il faut l'approcher du panier pour
moi ya une évolution qui on va devoir
avoir sur kendall brawn c'est en
première utilisation dans les premières
années l'utiliser comme imposant d'écran
effectivement lui donner la capacité
d'avoir plus d'espacé et de pouvoir
utiliser ses dribbles que
personnellement j'apprécie beaucoup et
et cette finesse dans le joueur et à
terme dans son développement parce que
je suis pas
humble ils veulent un incroyant de du
tiers outre mesure c'est ce jour-là lui
donner des ballons bale en a utilisé sa
capacité pour faire un décalage en un
contre un peut-être un petit peu tiré sa
capacité physique tôt c'est un peu ce
que malte vous dise est devenu du côté
de charlotte intéressante comparaison il
y a il ya des comparaisons aussi qu'ils
se font en termes de faible faible
volume de tirs avec des joueurs type
type claude robinson alors c'est pas
très flatteur mais où autoporteur un peu
plus flatteur quand même quand il était
à georgetown en termes de volumes de
tyrans n 6 et bien sûr autoporteur quel
devenir un shooter on va dire correct
en nba manu moi je si je regarde juste
les stades de candle brangeois
76 % aux lancers 38 à 3 points est ce
qu'il est vraiment du kata au shoot
puisque le pourcentage ne disent pas ça
si on regarde juste
chez b 6 et 14 filage mécanique assez
étrange déjà et
et ont même j'ai l'impression qu'en le
voyant même lui il sait qu'il n'a pas
bon au tir en fait
une pub coup il va pas forcément prendre
beaucoup il a 14 contre 36,4 en sont à
trois points
fou
et comment c'était un lycée au lycée il
était à plus adroits - est-ce qu'au
lycée il était plus adroits ou pas
non
non non ils allaient au circuit était
beaucoup beaucoup de transition beaucoup
de contre attaque contrée où il est très
très fort c'est sur les lignes de passes
ils coupent beaucoup beaucoup de lignes
de passe qui lui fait perdre pas mal
d'interception il a quasiment il a plus
de plus d'une interception par match la
cij a pas les stats exact mais peut-être
c'est ça ce qui lui permettait de du
coup ce
de partir en contre attaque plus seul
quoi est une marqué c'était
principalement ça il faisait pas
beaucoup de tirs pas beaucoup de l'attak
de cercle sur phases arrêtées oui
c'était 21 de serre tenté autre rapport
sur la dernière année pour cette
mijoro un volume de 182,6 au club
allemand et pour compte et pour
compléter tout fait rapidement sur le
tien il s'est fait engueuler par le
coaching stuff de beloeil au début
d'année les refuser tous hélas ces
derniers temps ils en prennent un peu
plus ou moins avec confiance il hésite
et plus et il avait re commence à ne
plus les prendre et le staff lui est
tombé dessus c'est quoi qui lui sont
tombés dessus et commença à les
reprendre dans un corner léa 8 sur 21
sur l'année
ce qui est un faible
une faible fréquence ces sales and alan
toi non plus tu crois pas aux tirs pas
du tout parce que si on croit pas du
tout aux tirs
ac à quel niveau on ne prend à la draft
et ça ne crois pas aux tirs pour l'en
comment les c'est pas une histoire de
pourcentage son histoire de volume
c'est-à-dire qu'il a il prend moins d'un
tir à trois points par match donc c'est
un enjeu footer prononcèrent que c'est
pas quelqu'un qui
continue sur le terrain il fait partie
des joueurs qu'on laisse pâtirait qu'on
close à hautefort sur qui on fait
attention sur les switch et tout ça
c'est marrant parce que j'étais relire
l'article qu'on avait écrit avec manu
sur donc le gars est qu'au début du 21e
tournoi lycéens etc en fait j'utilise et
céline qu'on avait écrit sur canal brown
et c'est j'ai l'impression le même jour
qu'on écrit qu'on décrit maintenant je
pense pas que c'est sa faute un que à
lui c'est aussi la faute à dès lors
qu'il comme on l'a dit on le dit depuis
le début de l'émission et pas
extrêmement créatif avec lui alors ça va
mieux depuis quelques de quelques matchs
tu as raison les blessures joue aussi
mais en fait on aurait pu attendre je
pense dans l'appart de béland était tous
très pourtant pillay à baylor et c'est
vrai qu'on a on était un peu déçu de
sauce qu'ils encourent en fait ce qu'ils
en feront comme même genre après sur le
tir moi je crois pas aux tirs pour le
moment pour l'instant ce sera plus un
genre de oued de brandon clark de nos
shooteurs en fait le nom shooter sur le
terrain mais en fait je peux pas non
plus trop le vc dans mon big board c'est
à dire le sortir d'un top 20 par exemple
un temps les quinzièmes toute assez haut
dans mon cher trop ans pour l'instant
parce que le profil physique le profil
athlétique de finisseur les flashs balle
en main de passes notamment c'est c'est
pas je pense je crois pas à ça a ses
qualités d'initiation mais je crois à
ses qualités de joueur qui fait le lien
des gens qui n'est pas là qui va pas
empêcher la fluidification d'une action
donc aux elle aurait une bille et
aujourd'hui ça reste quand même
important
il fait effectivement la même taille que
brandon clark
manu ce qui est ce qui te paraît avoir
les mêmes capacités athlétiques enfin
pas les mêmes mais des mêmes capacités
oui bah oui à peser sur un mètre passe
parce que venant mais je dis ça parce
que je regarde les chiffres il est ni
les y provoque pas énormément de stoxx
ni de style ni de blocks par rapport à
un brunch l'ars pas forcément le même
type de joueur non plus con way pour moi
c'est pas du tout le même style de jeu
que brendon clark je vois ce que veut
dire à l'homme dans le côté athlétique
dans l'utilisation
pour moi y'a vraiment il ya ce côté
finesse près du cercle kelly fait que
j'y crois vraiment fort sur un peu plus
qu'un mec juste qui posera des écrans
qui ont leur panier je parle pas de
comparaison et parle du fait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le nom serrano
shooter's 21 cambournac là c'est juste
famille eh ben on en est là ça
fonctionne pour rendre ça fonctionne pas
pour l'instant sur l'utilisation
ouais d'accord donc en fait je pourrais
tu aurais pu prendre un autre un autre
profil peut être bon mais aussi aux
dîmes pinch était mieux à la
commentaires en une 6è rang niveau nba
ce qu'au début prend pas beaucoup de
tirs loup y es-tu moulin n'en prenaient
pas beaucoup et c'est donc ce genre de
poste 4 un peu hybride pour pas dire le
mot le mot vulgaire mais qui devra
compenser par autre chose
et donc hugues toi tu la cinquième ça
veut dire que il va shooter à combien en
fait si shoot à 30% à coup on prend 6
shoots à 33 où on ne prend 6 shoots à 35
où on prend trois points je pars
je vais attendre qu'il shoote uniquement
catch and shoot je pense
vers les 35 37% au bout de la troisième
quatrième année pour pouvoir
effectivement laissé du spécisme sur le
terrain quand l apal bâle - mans et j'y
vais surtout attendre à la fin de son
contrat rookie qui puisse prendre le
ballon en main et qu'ils puissent se
créer du jeu lattaque individuellement
si genre comme un jour je te dis comme
un mal qui l'utilisent comme un pascal
csakan ce jour mon profil ok
sûr qu'on a une tentative par match tu
as 3 ans minimum quatre ou cinq on est
d'accord
ouais à peu près ok pour tout cas faut
qu'ils apprennent de la confiance est la
première étape pour lui se dire qu'il a
le droit de rodez c'est sûr et ensuite
et ce qui est ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui
une franchise nba qui offre ce luxe de
donner du temps de jeu et de d'attendre
le année 3 pour pour récolter les fruits
d'une draft top 10
sacramento
ramène tous les jours y sont ils ont
tellement envie d'avoir un ailier depuis
45 ans qu'ils le font écho sur l'a10 à
kokoro il ya deux ans de ça il a
combattu vais le tuer ce qui nous va
très bientôt
non mais c'est horrible mais c'est pas
une équipe qui va lui qui va le
développer à la perfection en fait déjà
aujourd'hui trois nouveaux jeunes femmes
au team à clerques alors un peu mieux
mais très effectivement et ce avant tout
exprimer cleveland oh regarde okoro ils
le prennent en quatrième position il
prenait part à trois points et
d'ailleurs ils ont mis en corner c'est
désastreux et pourtant l'équipe
maintenant elle est chaude éraillée plus
personne n'est pas le com de cleveland
comme une équipe de fond du trou et oui
où tu dois pas aller
oui les choses changent rapidement
donc en fait le plan le plan de hugues
secrètement c'est que sacramento gras
draft kendall brand est ensuite victor
wang manière voilà c'est ça exactement
avec tales et burton john mitchell ce
que tu fais
alors
ok au métier donc c'est quoi penser quoi
vous pourquoi vous n'êtes pas d'accord
en fait pourquoi une un kilt eux tu l'as
mis combien du coup alan je me dis que
tu avais bouger 11e 15e bon à ukiah
cinquième c'est quoi la différence sur
que vous n'êtes pas d'accord je vois pas
de stars potentielles je vois pas de je
vois je vois plus loin un rôle pays
un rôle terrain tu crois pas un créateur
mouscron craindre individuel il n'a pas
le dribble il n'a pas le droit n'est pas
truquée il n'a pas de la penthrite dit
la pie la pâle il n'a pas la capacité à
éliminer un contrat parce que c'est un
très bel athlète verticale mais sur le
premier par la création de séparation
d'un point a vers un point b arrêtée il
peut pas le faire et je n'ai pas vu le
faire donc alors peut-être qu'il peut le
faire jusqu'à surpris je n'ai pas vu à
sunrise christiane c'était canine
chandler qui gérait tout l'attaquent
cette année à baylor ces espèces de mix
entre flagler akins autre des petits mis
les petits gouard de baylor moi je crois
plus lui un rôle player plus c'est à
dire un joueur qui peut attaquer des
peut-être attaqué des clauses out qui va
être utilisé sur
pris de décision sur short roll qui peut
finir proche du panier et donc je vois
pas de stars potentielles je peux pas
drafté savoir ça dans un de mes deux
premiers tiers c'est juste ça je vois
pas un starter plus chez canal brunch
peux me tromper bien sûr mais si aaron
gordon non aaron gordon glémée les
meilleurs meilleur scénario possible ce
serait à vendre ' nous sommes mariés
mais je vois pas ça arrive et shawn
marion ne sait ce que kenza lebron
rêverez dette mais c'est un mec qui est
4 fois all-star donc je pense moi et le
mec qui fait des matches à 40 points en
play-offs toujours pas qu'elle n'a le
droit de faire ça et aaron gordon s'est
pas l'athlète quelqu'un iron honnêtement
je pense qu'on sous cote un peu
historiquement ce qui est assez clair on
veut redonner ses terres en gordon
c'est un athlète plus plus plus et
je pense à bien meilleur joueur proche
du cercle
donc je vois j'aime le joueur que j'aime
je pense qu'il sera utile il aura
plusieurs contres en nba mais je vois
pas jean par l incroyable ça et que vous
voulez
manu est ce que est ce que tu peux
arbitres et s'il te plaît est ce que
pour toi il serait dans un tir 2 dans un
tiers 3 même
nom mais en fait genre c'est un joueur
que je suis assez bizarre c'est bizarre
sur sur lui je suis pas fan de ce que je
vois
mais j'en veux énormément envie d'y
croire
je par rapport au halal est athlétique
comme ça ça peut toujours servir je le
fais des flaques de quelques poulets pan
ex cool qui me dit qu'il va qui sait le
faire et que s'ils entrent dans un les
mains dans un bon staff nba il va
pouvoir le développer ça elle savait que
bénéfique pour son jeu
mais faut voilà faut vraiment que le
kisob policiers pour je ne sais pas trop
si doit
aller à la draft ou attendre un an de
plus
parce que je crois que c'est un bon
bah je sais pas le train l'année
prochaine ils vont se retrouver avec
de de ward qui vont avoir besoin de la
balle qui sont des gros scoreur il ce
risque iris d'être un peu plus effacé
avoir encore beaucoup moins de ballons
que ce qu'il a cette année
donc c'est ici que c'est compliqué on
aime bien il faut qu'il ait le bon
environnement autres commencent et c'est
peut-être kata et on se retrouve dans
une situation à la main 8 mile est dans
un joueur qui joue pas au bout d'un
moment on peut parler de la valeur qu'il
aurait puisque la valeur c'est à la fois
la rareté du profil donc vous allez me
parler de ça et c'est aussi
je dirais l'adaptabilité du joueur dans
combien de contexte différent il peut
réussir
à la nuque est-ce que et est ce que pour
vous c'est sur ces deux critères là il
est plus haut que par exemple d'autres
d'autres joueurs de ces drafts qui ce
qui veut dire qu'ils seraient top 15 top
10 personnes
là la rare la rareté d'un joueur
qui util des deux côtés du terrain
pouvant vivre sans ballon mais qui est
un bol stoppeur donc un genre qui un
trou noir c'est toujours intéressant
c'est toujours intéressant à voir dans
une rotation parce que il faut des
connecteurs et dans une ligue 2 stars il
faut quand même des toutes les équipes
qui ont des porteurs de bras les ont des
joueurs qui ont besoin de l'aval pour
évoluer pourra toujours faire sans
songer aux médias sa chasse et je pense
que c'est pour ça que je les voulais
quand même dans mon tir trois points
juste un joueur que je pense un vrai
futur nvier faut pas croire que les 60
joueurs ils vont se faire attraper ou un
futur nba c'est toujours ce que j'essaie
de dire
il y en a quand tu manques a rien que tu
essayes de dire que le potentiel de bust
est assez faible finalement c'est ça
pour moi ya pas que pour être potter
parente potentiel de boeuf chacun a le
droit mais ya pas vraiment de potentiel
de all star all nba
troisième plus jeune meilleur joueur
d'une équipe qui va qui va ou pour moi
ça peut être un solide starter pas plus
par contre la question que j'ai pour
hugues c est ce que tu l'as en 5 parce
que tu n'aimes pas grand monde dans la
deuxième partie de cette loterie parce
que pour moi c'est plus un révélateur de
sa en réalité chez le queens
ya lieu de ça ils accueillaient de la
rareté du profil dans la cuvée draft je
l'avais en 5 je pense que mj griffin va
passer devant parce que j'ai enfin pu
regarder beaucoup beaucoup de jerry finn
et voilà mais julia quasi aucun ailier
qui peut porter la balle est créé balle
en main et du fait que ce soit des sols
c'est ce côté athlétique et cette
finesse ça me fait énormément monté tu
mets une cuvée avec
plus délié qui peuvent porter la balle
peut-être qu'il tombe beaucoup plus bas
la dernière est celle de sharp et dans
la draft mais tu te rached en charge
devant cameron j'en sais rien parce que
j'ai de fortes gelées parce que moi je
sais de ne charger il a annoncé qu'ils
joueraient pas cette année à kentucky
arche pas ce que ça veut dire pour ça
dans ça veut pas dire qu'il va pas se
présenter non non c'est clair
moi je pensais plus à révélateur de bata
comme on l'a dit c'est pas une grotte
qui est très fort et très
avec pau temps des potentiels star sur
les postes de garde c'est c'est des gens
communes sont un peu moins base qui sont
un peu plus bas sur tahiti washington
john hardy kate chandler peu le mec
comme jane du renne fait que la peau sa
position et son poste de pivot et moins
values à blolequin canal brawn je pense
que ça peut s'entendre qu'il est aussi
haut mais je pense que puissant
révélateur du fait que pas dans cette
deuxième partie de loterie c'est moins
la chic on pourrait penser
on à nu par le monde de la défense de
kendall brown la manière dont il défend
puisqu'on en parle de peter comme un
teint tout wyplayer tout et ça veut dire
des deux côtés on n'a pas parlé mais moi
défense que j'apprécie surtout chez lui
c'est qu'il est actif c'est ce que je
disais au début sur les lignes de passes
ce qui me permettent d'intercepter des
ballons ou du moins que les effectifs je
ne sais plus comment les détourner pas
mal d'action et ça j'aime beaucoup après
sur le un contrat j'ai un peu plus de
mal surtout face à aux joueurs rapides
donc les extérieurs en 2 3 là j'ai un
peu plus de doute et j'ai bien peur
qu'ils puissent uniquement des phones
sur sur des quatre en fait finalement et
il va devoir un petit peu soulever de la
fonte s'il veut voir un peu plus loin
quoi donc moi j'aime bien les outils
qu'il a en défense
après faut voir comment il sera
développé c'est là c'est plus le
développement sur le monde j'ai peur
qu'on sait faire des choses mais c'est
encore pour moi trop limité sur le
développement il ya toujours la question
psychologique hughes est ce qu'on peut
en toucher un mot même si bon on a pas
on n'a pas trop de deux d'insiders on
connaît personne dans le staff mais
encore on essaye mais
qu'est ce que tu peux nous dire de
l'attitude
si je te donne mon ressenti avant mon
moi je le trouve par exemple - j'aime
moins son attitude que celle de jérémy
soeur anne so chance pour ceux qui
veulent prononcer la française je trouve
moins compétitif sur un terrain je
trouve - ouais mon compétitive c'est le
mot
il est - il est moins agressif il est
moins focus surtout je trouve que
belouin couvre très très bien la naïveté
encore de kendall bonne
c'est fait avoir sur beaucoup de
démarquage loin du ballon il est parfois
pas focus et à une excellente défense
abbey lors avec eux jérémy soran mais
aussi flottants de bas le pivot
titulaire et jonathan cheechoo a qui
sont vraiment des excellents défenseurs
qui couvre beaucoup de choses
du coup voilà très encore très très
jeune et sur le côté physique je rejoins
menu aprem latéral je pense qu'il peut
défendre des ailiers quand même mais les
états ce sera très difficile où il est
très bon c'est sûr les trappes
est ce que vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter sur kendall brown
messieurs 1 sur ces super dommage de pas
l'avoir vu au fibo parce que je pense
vraiment qu à côté de chet à la place de
kalkbrenner
voilà où nous de calais zouk lover diouf
qui était là parce qu'en réalité un des
membres du staff était matte painter des
chutes
ça aurait été super parce que quand on
va en parler pour un autre joueur comme
qui patrick baldwin un contexte où il a
peut-être moins de responsabilités il
joue avec des vraies stars entre gré
parce que cette équipe là on a trouvé
peut-être un petit peu sous coté à un
moment mais j'étais naïve itx est une
graine kate chandler john allan davis il
y avait quand même des vrais des vrais
joueurs franchement ça aurait été
intéressant de voir et peut-être qu'il
aurait été utilisé différemment
peut-être parce que à baylor ou à
scénariste chris sutton l'an dernier
sait on l'a pas pas trop trop trop vite
voilà justin young man u quelque chose à
ajouter
il est très bon pointu raté
c'est clair avec ce run c'est la belle
peur
regardez le regarder
les flashes du dribble et puis après
vous venez choisir votre contre allan et
moi et on est la sortie
on recrute
on va faire un baptême c'est vrai que
belle chevelure et mais moi j'ai
vraiment beaucoup d'amour pour jérémy
soran on va faire un peu de cassure lui
mais le décolorés en 2022 j'adore
vraiment je peux vous puissiez change
tout mais oui mais je peux vous dire en
fait c'est un brésilien
ici font tout ça je te le dis c'est un
brésilien serait
extraordinaire
nous avons une question désormais pour
finir dans la légèreté donc sur sur
notre ami ken dahl brand manu nous l'a
dit son père a joué un peu international
il a notamment joué en suisse
et donc je vais vous demander de voter
parmi ces fromages typiquement suisse et
d'appellation d'origine protégée j'ai
fait j'ai fait des recherches et j'ai
exclu le vacherin mont d'or puisqu'il
est également
produit en france le vacherin mont-d'or
donc ça compte pas donc vous aviez le
choix entre gruyère emmental tête de
moine et raclette je sais que une
cuisine donc une goutte sur la primeur
du vote là la pression de faux vrai que
ma femme elle puisse confirmer à la
raclette sans discussion possible en
plus un truc de fainéants parfait
raclette manu c'est validé je me
demandais comment tu le manges en fait
qu'est ce que c'est vraiment là si on
parle fromage à raclette tu ne manges
raclette chemin normal ou si on mange
comme ça pour le fun avec ou sans croûte
wavre tu le manges comme
s'ils mangent comme tu veux tu manges
comme tu veux vraiment c'est le meilleur
fromage tente un petit appareil pour
faire chauffer tu peux faire des
croque-monsieur tu peux faire tu peux
faire plein de trucs c'est un droit de
faire ce que tu veux
raclette
inquiète et chez alan tête de moine mais
oui
parce que c'est
je suis un hipster mais c'est
extraordinaire je pensais que personne
n'avait dit recettes le moine tête de
moine c'est en plus ça se coupe je sais
pas si tu si tu vois cet appareil oui le
parti coppola
extraordinaire des moines leur attaque
tête de moine
vous par respect pour nicolas mathieu je
ne vais pas donner ta vanne sur lui sur
la tête de pointe du geek moi si tu peux
le dire nico si tu m'entends j'ai des
cabines tête de moine
je vois très bien que la toge et qui
s'intéresserait incroyable c'est clair
c'est vrai qu'ils pourraient être sur la
sur l'emballage sur l'emballage des des
têtes de moine quoi
messieurs kendall breendonk et la
raclette vainqueur de ce podcast
vainqueur on sait pas mais pour kendall
brand mais pour la raclette oui une
valeur sûre c'est certain pour canal
brandon vera dans les années à venir en
nba on se retrouve très bientôt pour un
prochain podcast abonnez vous sur votre
si vous écoutez puisque si possible vous
ne vous écoutiez sûr sur youtube sur au
chat on est aussi présent sur toutes les
plateformes d'écouté donc si vous avez
un abonnement vous avez juste à vous
abonner à notre podcast pour recevoir la
petite motifs qui va bien quand ça sort
donc ça c'est très utile abonnez-vous
également youtube twitter c'est à g
twitch toussa toussa
et à venir sur twitch ont fait un petit
teasing hub pour finir
une deuxième partie avec la loupe la
loupe des des pros c'est à dire qu'on
regarde des matchs de prospects avec
l'oeil des deux joueurs professionnels
savent exactement où on va les gens les
gros bâbord comme 10 niko ça va être
incroyable
excellent excellent très bon teasing
on se retrouve pour un prochain pocas
merci manu merci à l'âne merci et merci
à vous qui avez écouté et bisous tout le
monde ciao